il est une fois dans le creux d'une
vallée un tout petit village ça vous est
familier les conter les histoires sont
des éléments culturels incontournables
que ce soit pour les sociétés passées ou
pour nos sociétés modernes
on est entouré de contes et d'histoires
on a été bercé par des romans et des
récits on a grandi avec des fables et
des légendes
en fait on est tellement entouré de
mythe et d'univers fantastiques qu'on en
viendrait presque à oublier qui font
partie de notre quotidien
on en vient presque à oublier à quel
point nos influences on en vient presque
à oublier à quel point il nous importe
ce tout petit village il y avait la
grand place et ce soir là sur la grand
place du tout petit village il y avait
foule il y avait les enfants des femmes
des vieillards des hommes il y avait un
juge et un condamné à mort il y avait un
bourreau et un échafaud n'a quoi peuvent
servir les histoires on a vu la
sélection naturelle tend à supprimer ce
qui n'est pas vraiment utile
certes il peut y avoir des dérives
génétique mais les histoires semblent si
omniprésente à travers les civilisations
elle semble constamment joué un rôle si
importante pour nos sociétés qu'il
serait étonnant que ces histoires ne
soit qu'un accident de l'évolution en
lui coupe la tête quand dallas où on les
coupe la paix pour histoire
où valois à paris si les histoires sont
fiés omniprésente dans notre quotidien
ce n'est pas un hasard harari va même
jusqu'à affirmer que l'histoire serait
la plus importante innovation d
l'histoire de l'humanité les histoires
nous ont permis de croire qu'il fallait
être courageux intelligent bienveillante
curieux travailleurs charitable sincère
souriant et tolérant les histoires nous
amène à réfléchir sur ce que l'on est ce
que l'on veut être elle nous invite à
devenir meilleur tu as à dire demandé
aux juges de condamner l etat verdien
remonter un mais pour harari le rôle d
histoire est bien plus important que
cela pendant des millions d'années la
terre était habité par des hominidés
avec des grands cerveaux des sociétés
organisées et des outils développés
cependant ces hominidés était inoffensif
leur impact sur leur environnement et
minimes
il était comparable à celui des
chimpanzés et le nombre de ces hominidés
n'a jamais dépassé les quelques dizaines
de milliers et ça c'est fou quand vous y
pensez le nombre d'abonnés à cette
chaîne est supérieure à la population
totale en hominidés lily à 70 mille ans
et puis selon harari tout à coup quelque
chose a changé
qu'est ce qui a changé c'est notre
capacité à coopérer à grande échelle
laquelle repose selon harari sur les
mythes que l'on partage pensez-y
individuellement 1 humant même avec son
grand cerveau c'est un peu un bon à rien
si vous larguer un humain et un champion
est sur une île déserte ya de bonnes
chances que ce soit l'humeur qui meurent
en premier pour harare
la différence majeure entre les humains
et les chimpanzés
ce sont les mythes sur lesquels repose
la coopération humaine en particulier
les chanteuses et ont toujours beaucoup
de mal à coopérer avec d'autres
chimpanzés qui ne connaissent pas alors
ça ça ne pose pas énormément de
problèmes s'il n'y a que 50 s'imposer
dans un groupe puisque les chimpanzés
finiront par tous se connaître et aux
pires ragots après ragots chacun
prendrait finira par avoir entendu
parler de tous les autres chimpanzés
cependant au delà de 100 chimpanzés se
devient vite ce bordel
les expériences suggèrent que les
chimpanzés sont incapables de coopérer
en grand nombre al'inverse les sociétés
humaines sont capables de coopérer dans
des civilisations aux populations
heureusement grande nous sommes capables
de coopérer à 1010 me voir des millions
pour construire des avions des monuments
ou toute une culture web en particulier
contrairement aux chimpanzés
nous sommes tout à fait capables de
coopérer avec des humains que l'on ne
connaît pas du tout comment est ce
possible pour harari la clé et
l'ensemble des fictions que nous
partageons nous avons tous été bercé par
des histoires illustrant l'importance du
partage de la bienveillance ou de
l'honnêteté
si bien que nous croyons que ceux avec
qui nous coopérons vont eux aussi
attaché de l'importance au partage à la
bienveillance et à l'honnêteté et c'est
cette croyance commune qui nous permet
de coopérer avec des 20 individus que
l'on a pourtant jamais rencontré le
condamne et demande trois jours de répit
pour aller de l'autre côté de la vallée
dire adieu aux siens 3 jours de répit à
un cheval et jure il donne sa parole
qu'il reviendra par exemple l'une des
fictions les plus importantes de
l'humanité
l argent aujourd'hui on s'accordent tous
sur le fait qu'un bout de papier
pourvu qu'il soit imprimé de manière
convenable a de la valeur pourtant il ne
s'agit que d'un bout de papier pour les
motifs sont jolies mais pourquoi est-ce
que ce bout de papier a acquis de la
valeur au point qu'aujourd'hui on est
capable de l'échanger contre de la
nourriture voir contre le service et le
travail de quelqu'un d'autre et bien à
bien y réfléchir et vous renvoie vers
une vidéo d'eurêka à ce sujet ce qui
fait que ce bout de papier a de la
valeur c'est notre croyance commune dans
le fait qu'il a de la valeur l'argent
c'est une fiction une fiction qui nous
racontait tous les jours et dans ton
histoire
on en vient à oublier qu'il ne s'agit
que d'une fiction
néanmoins le fait que nous croyons tous
en cette fiction commune suffit à la
rendre utile et à convaincre le
pizzaïolo de me donner une pizza contre
un bout de papier les fictions n'ont
aucunement besoin d'être vrai pour
changer le cours de l'histoire juge
regarde le condamné et sourire voilà les
erreurs voire revient à condition que
quelqu'un que tu as remplace ici les
fictions les plus p
acculèrent dans l'histoire de l'humanité
sont celles qui parviennent à une fière
des humains si fort entre qui sont prêts
à mourir au nom de leurs fictions les
zones sont battus et sont morts pour le
droit sacré à démocratie l'exemple
typique est bien sûr celui des pays
réfléchissez y
est ce que la france existe vraiment est
ce que le concept de france renvoie bien
à quelque chose de tangible selon harare
clairement pas en revanche c'est ça qui
importe
nous croyons tous en cette fiction et
cette croyance commune dans cette
fiction nous permet de nous unir pour
amener à bout des projets de grande
envergure que ce soit elle est supportée
ensemble une équipe de football et lire
un individu qui parle au nom de tous les
français
vous acceptez les lois du pays comme
l'affirment harari la réelle différence
entre nous et les chimpanzés et la col
mythique qui lie ensemble un grand
nombre d'individus de familles et de
groupes grâce à sept cols mythiques
selon harari les fictions ont permis à
homo sapiens de passer de petite tribu
avec une centaine d'individus où tout le
monde devait se connaître pour coopérer
à des civilisations de plusieurs
milliers voire millions voire milliard
d'individus ou grâce aux histoires
communes dans cette civilisation tout
humain pouvait désormais coopérer avec
un autre même s'il ne l'avait jamais
rencontrée tout ça au nom de fiction
qu'il aurait été comme une reine et
d'erreurs voire obtient à condition que
pétain que te remplace ici les gens ont
ri dans l'instant jusqu'à qu'un drame se
lève mois moi je remplacerais le
condamner à montupet faction gfu il ne
reviendra jamais à des barbelés sur un
an si on en croit harari nos
civilisations humaines repose donc sur
de nombreuses fictions tente on sous
estime grandement l'importance le
psychologue jonathan wright ajoute à
tout cela toutes les structures qui nous
lie socialement et sans lesquels nos
civilisations chuterait tel un château
de cartes ait appel tout ce qui nous lie
socialement le capital mourad le capital
moral inclus tous ces éléments de
culture qui facilite une relation aux
uns ou aux autres et
qui veille à imphy au bon fonctionnement
de nos sociétés c'est ce qui me permet
de laisser mon vélo quelque part à
lausanne sans craindre de voir ses roues
disparaître alors on est venu remplacer
le condamné l'attentât comment ces trois
hommes au terme de la troisième journée
quand bururi venu chercher le
remplacement du condamné à mort au moins
on a entendu le gallo d'un cheval est
elle condamnée à mort qui rentrait il
venait reprendre ta place
malheureusement à l'instar d' harari ait
affirme que nous avons tendance à
sous-estimer ce capital moral
typiquement les athées vont s'interdire
de voter pour un parti affilié à une
religion sous prétexte que selon eux la
religion n'est qu'une fiction
pourtant si on en croit wright il est
tout à fait possible d'être athée et de
voter pour un parti religieux notamment
si l'on pense que le capital moral est
fragile et qu'il risque de s'effondrer
en votant pour un autre parti
alors je dis pas qu'il faut voter pour
les partis religieux mais j'aimerais
attirer votre attention sur cette
citation de jonathan wright
si vous essayez de changer votre
organisation ou autre société si vous ne
considérez pas les effets de ces
changements sur le capital moral vous
chercher les ennuis
la foule s'est alors tourné vers leurs
en plateau pour lui dire mais comment tu
investis comment savait-il reviendra lui
a répondu il se trouve que je préfère
mourir plutôt que de vivre dans un monde
où la parole n'a pas valeur
ce qu'il faut
ça c'est que les petites histoires et
les grands mythes qui soit fondé sur une
réalité ou non joue un rôle crucial dans
nos sociétés ils sont le socle de notre
capital moral un grand merci à 6 du
mambo pour sa participation à cette
vidéo que vous avez mais ces
interventions si du mambo et compose
professionnels de rencontrer au tremplin
de planica
d'ailleurs je présenterai à tmx laquelle
le 30 novembre prochain dans les bacs au
tremplin de tjx s'acquiert sylvie a fait
une présentation des trois minutes sur
le rôle des comptes et c'était juste
génial juste adoré et lui demander de
participer ici j'étais très heureux
qu'elle accepte
j'aimerais insister sur le fait que bon
là en vidéo je trouve que c'est vraiment
cool tu n'oserais quand on jette encore
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup plus
tellement que juste après sa
présentation je vais avoir vu dit
pourquoi cette vidéo les enfants on a
parlé du paradoxe de la morale on avait
commencé à essayer de voir comment la
morale pouvait être une construction
évolutionnaire et on s'était pas mal
attardé sur le rôle d'une gêne dans la
construction de la morale questeur qui
implique ce premier et françois mary 2
mais se demande si la morale est
vraiment quelque chose de génétique et
en particulier six premiers se demande
si ils ne seraient pas dangereux de
supposer qu'il y a une cause génétique à
notre moral bien sûr dans la morale que
l'on a
il ya autre chose que l'effet de nos
gènes ceci étant dit et dépasse en effet
contre intuitive les gènes ont vraiment
un rôle important sur la morale du
lendemain comment il ya des études de
jumeaux qui ont raconté dans le bouquin
de joe wright où il raconte que des
vrais jumeaux séparés à la naissance ont
bien pu souvent les mêmes convictions
politiques et pas que des convictions
politiques plein de choses sur leurs
préférences morale que les frères et
soeurs qui ont grandi dans la même
famille parfait pas dire quelles
convictions éthiques sont entièrement
déterminés par une gêne qui se passera
sans doute c'est qu'il faut avoir des
petites variations qui est un peu petit
plus enclins à certaines vidéos d'autres
idées comme on étire certains scrutins
démocratiques qui tendrait plutôt à
diviser cas unir cette petite divergence
initiale peut faire que l'un va se
retrouver dans certains environnements
sociaux et l'autre donne d'autres
environnements sociaux avec la
ségrégation sociale idéologie qui les
sépare les
car qu'on peut avoir du coût des idées
politiques très différentes alors qu'au
début ils seront finalement assez
proches mais du coup ça veut quand même
dire que des petites variations
génétiques initial peuvent conduire à
des divergences dans les opinions
politiques et donc que nos préférences
morales sont au moins en partie
significativement influencées par le
juge quant à savoir si cela est
dangereux voire c'est une question très
difficile mais je pense que si on est
conscient que notre moral est en partie
celle que nos gènes nous donne je pense
que ça permet de se rendre compte que la
morale que l'on intuitivement n'a pas
plus de raison d'être vu ce que la
morale d'un autre âge en particulier ça
tend à montrer que l'amour à clooney
n'est pas une morale universelle du tout
c'est une morale qui a été grandement
influencé par ce qui est encodé dans nos
gènes et je pense que ça ça nous pousse
à remettre en question ce qui est notre
moral est à chercher un moyen peu plus
souhaitable et on y viendra dans deux
vidéos en parlant du tourisme avec
monsieur philippe donc un rake va
également dans ce sens et souligne notre
capacité d'adaptation et ça c'est un
point très important et qui est
longuement discuté par harare dans son
livre notamment sapience c'est le fait
que contrairement aux jeunes les
fictions évolue très rapidement et sont
capables de s'adapter à un contexte
socio-économique qui a été bouleversée
au cours des derniers millénaires et
bien sûr pour les gènes quelques
millénaires
c'est finalement relativement peu de
temps pour vraiment s'adapter et du coup
si on en croit harry et me semble si tu
veux un temps wright en parle dans son
livre sur pouvoir rapidement s'adapter
un contexte socio économique changeant
bas les jeunes les plus utiles sont ceux
qui
nous laisse la possibilité de nous
adapter par opposition à des jeunes qui
seraient plus dogmatique qui nous
empêcheraient d'abandonner notre doc
inite rieuse soit 86 9 sec aussi schwarz
font la remarque que du coup ce qui
importe vraiment au niveau de la
sélection depuis quelques mineurs du
pays vise à sion humaine n'est plus la
sélection naturelle alors sélection
naturelle au sens sélection dans un état
de nature et c'est non mais on vit dans
société depuis bien plus que quelques
moulinets vie en société depuis des
centaines de milliers d'années
est-ce que la sélection qui s'applique
alors à l'échelle de la société est
encore une sélection naturelle
oui table terme audebert unis en fait ce
qu'ils font c'est vraiment le concept de
sélection pas tant le mot naturel
toujours des tic finalement au cours des
derniers millénaires les conditions ont
tellement évolué conditions de vies
humaines contexte socio-économique des
humains a tellement évolué que les
pressions de sélection sur les gènes des
humains ont sans doute été beaucoup plus
importants au cours des derniers
millénaires qu'au cours des centaines de
milliers d'années qui précédait c'est en
tout cas la thèse que défend jonathan a
été dans son livre qui prétend que la
sélection génétique n'a jamais été aussi
important ce que depuis que utilisations
humaines ont grossi et en particulier
son nom jonathan wright
ça a créé une sélection accrue des
jeunes qui sont notamment capables de
croire les fictions qui sont autour
d'eux et de s'adapter aux nouvelles
fictions kit a rejeté les précédentes
enfin bo quentin et en aiguille se
demande comment est-ce que les
comportements immoraux pu persister
si la coopération est tu as été la
meilleure stratégie du coup il fallait
tout faire pour pouvoir opérer
bah je dirais que le modèle de tefana
est un modèle très amplifiée en
finalement comme tout modèle
en pratique il ya sans doute beaucoup de
cas où être immoral et finalement une
stratégie optimale si on veut se
reproduire un maximum l'exemple
archétype de cela c'est dj scan qui aura
eu un très très grand nombre de
descendants par piles et et empereur et
que du coup il a eu le droit de violer
toujours est il qu'à cause de cela un
très grand nombre d'asiatiques les
froisser une majorité d'asiatiques sont
en outre moi y compris
some descendants de gengis khan du coup
on a des bouts de gênes de gengis khan
et si janot là sont pas forcément ceux
du partage égalitaire
bien sûr la réalité est beaucoup plus
compliqué que le modèle de ses fans et
tous les modèles sont faux ça n'empêche
pas le modèle de stéphane d'être utile
pour comprendre l'émergence de la morale
du reste comme le fait remarquer
protocole et différentes hypothèses
l'émergence de la morale qui fit
pourquoi est ce qu on a l'amour a
aujourd'hui sont pas forcément en
compétition les unes avec les autres et
sont peut-être plutôt complémentaires
notamment chacune parvient à expliquer
des aspects un petit peu différent de la
morale que l'on a aujourd'hui c'est
j'espère que vous allez aimer cette
vidéo la prochaine fois on va finir
notre description évolutionnaire de la
morale avec une vidéo sur l'instance
tribales
en particulier on va expliquer
l'hooliganisme à partir de la théorie de
l'évolution
il ya un certain modèle d'évolution d'un
appel la sélection de groupes
si vous avez aimé cette vidéo pour
salies qui a commencé à la partager
pensez à vous abonner pour une parenté
futurs épisodes mercier qui porte aux
ordres et j'espère que vous serez là la
prochaine fois l'argent c'est ce qu'on
veut tout ce qui importe est que tout le
monde soit d'accord
si moi je pense une paire de chaussettes
c'est de l'argent mais que mon boulanger
n'est pas d'accord paris va avoir du mal
à acheter ni croissance en revanche si
on est tous les deux d'accord alors dans
quelle paire de chaussettes peut très
bien servir comme moyen de paiement
c'est parce que la marmotte elle met le
chocolat dans le sociétal est longue est
élu par des rythmes investing fictionnel
story everybody au pays de seine hauts
de seine pour un non
[Musique]